jones et squeeze aujourd'hui on se
trouve une nouvelle fois sur speed run
heures n'avaient fait une vidéo dessus
il ya quelques temps pour ceux qui ne se
souviennent pas des règles je les mets
dans la description est en gros c'est
une course depuis la vidéo qu'on avait
faite sur le jeu il ya quatre nouveaux
personnages qui ont été rajoutés
fonctionne bien mais voilà qu'à la c2 je
vous laisse les découvrir chez toi ça
vous plairait et voilà ça va me cale on
ne s'attend pas à ce qui nous attend des
rockets médias je tente un truc pour toi
réside pour be ok parce que je
m'appelais bambi aussi balancé missiquoi
alors que le missile anti tout est gagné
des matches pas eu de réaction quoi
tellement c'était violent
j'ai pratiqué la noue réaction il est
fier de lui c'est vraiment offrir deux
mecs mais complexé quoi elle est on de
la mer vers toi tu ça c'est fait rire ça
toi hop là bas si j'insiste au j'avais
pas vu j'ai découvert plein les jambes
tu fais quoi
déjà on se calme je sais pas mais tu as
un chat mignon donc forcément tu es
monté regarde le maître tiff les grosses
pattes quoi
cadets allez on évite les animaux les
enfants c'est tellement top teams au nom
et à brugheas était monde quoi je suis
cascadeurs professionnels dans ses
droits
je le savais le missile dans le chaton
hop là adieu le choix parmi nous avoir
découvert mon âme plénel jaboulay et
faisait du surplace quoi c'est juste
parce qu'on était en pauvre il y avait
là toujours là bas c'était la bonne
mais c'était une jolie chorégraphie
finalement rien de cap et qu il parte à
une plongée génial japon à cause de toi
on perd la gamme superbe dans la salle
tout cas grec dans sa phrase tu sentais
qu'il est en train de perdre et aucun
pour les moi j'adore passer par là tous
les jours j'aime passer par là rien rien
rien rien
ap la caisse et moi j'aime bien mais
j'aime bien j'ai rien la zone rouge
attend attend déjà
ok les gars là je vais faire un peu plus
du monde ça rien fait mais la via un
envoi aux personnes labo avec gilles a
répété tranche de me toucher la joue
avec deux doigts
c'était incroyable tout dans le silence
en plus acquis
vas-y ok c'est fini lui casser la gueule
mais qu'elle peut faire barrage
pardon ta gueule alors alors que hier
dans la rage on essaie les autres
animaux le 19 mai c'était un bordel en
bas allez c'est tellement beau ah oui
merci aucun problème aucun problème oh
non non elle à bout mais elle est
tellement rôle où mon gars c'est comme
si je te faisais ça tanger pas tarder
voila voila c'est comme si je te faisais
ça bon bref ça n'allait pas trop votre
art est non à aa
c'est horrible
pas là
matt est non alors mais regarde holtet
sont prévisibles à la sauvette moi je
suis un programme
moi je en fait si je suis le mec qui
quittent tac rosstat d'accord c'était le
mec dans les incombe rochelle à lahti
moyenne qui accroche toro double clé est
là encore gagné mais [ __ ] ce alors à
ça fait très plaisir sans renvoi cd oui
la lépi qui met sprint il encore à
chaque fois ils sont la honte attaque un
haut plateau
g skill et mouiller à la route hélas ça
n'a pas suffi c'est parti pour le mode
only grappa
le groupe tient aussi au fait c'est quoi
la récréation tailleur pour faire coucou
si je le fais moi bah samassa attend
attend dé moi la pluie de roquettes
qu'est-ce qu'on fait du corps non rien
de rien bah c'est une bombe
j'ai vu me tais une balle rebondissante
j'aime bien correspondait missiles mica
haut de mon prochain
c'est un bon jour
non en ce que j'ai mangé leur idiote
parce que j'aime roger dans la gueule
quoi tous les missiles ils ont dit à un
petit chat mignon non non aux voix
criarde parce que je les regarde et
pontiac poursuit mois qu'est ce qui se
passe je te tire dessus d'en bas je
cherche le coq
ça c'était pas l'échec
larry m'en fous je m'en fous je
m'approche as they pas mal ça non
we know avec un fusil à tanger pas de
fusil j'arrive j'ai produit par ubisoft
s'en charger
tout comme plus inoffensif d'une
grenouille et casse pour toi il a tapé
bien pris le premier tonneau pour bien
tomber sur le deuxième site mais les
gars les gars personne n'a voulu de ma
pitié ces mois sont allés trop vite j'ai
vu sur la gauche dégringoler les piques
m t'es sûr pourquoi tu ris et ça par
contre je me faire tuer caché dans la bd
et voilà on termine sur sa cette
magnifique vidéo
je suppose que personne d'autre vu notre
parti une dernière à c'est la fin de la
vidéo excusez moi j'étais en termes de
création favoris qui consiste à regarder
mon mur en cellule on se retrouve très
vite dans sa nouvelle vidéo chat monfils
[Musique]